so is it cool to sit in the front for
these things
like uh
oh really yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
but the wives get to come every day so
where the
primary is
tonight
other things occurring
oh yeah okay i'll let you out of this
that's the apc
for like 30 years oh do you want to
get it labeled for next time to help
those
no
so if you're ever in my seat if you want
me to announce it publicly in front of
everybody you're going to need to ask me
i'm sorry
um
characters when you go back
hello yes
six four six
not at all
foreign
um
well the moment
good afternoon i have a few uh
elements at the top so we'll go ahead
and get started uh
first as you all know the department
yesterday lost a giant
we all know that secretary schultz was a
foreign policy visionary
who helped herald the peaceful end of
the cold war
and whose legacy left us safer from the
specter
of the world's most dangerous weapons
what may be less well-known however
are the profound ways in which he shaped
this institution
he was a champion of the women and men
of the department
and it's no accident that our foreign
service institute
bears his name as the secretary said
yesterday the work we do now
and will do well into the future will be
shaped
by secretary schultz's legacy we send
our deepest condolences to secretary
schultz's family and loved ones
turning to india where a burst glacier
yesterday resulted in landslides and
floods
our thoughts are with the our indian
friends and partners during this
challenging time
we extend our deepest condolences to the
family and friends of the deceased
and we hope for a successful rescue
effort and a speedy and full recovery
for the
for the injured moving on to the u.s
decision to re-engage with the human
rights council
which was formally announced this
morning this morning the secretary
announced the
immediate u.s re-engagement with the u.n
human rights council
that process is already underway in
geneva where the u.s mission today
participated in a regular organizational
meeting
of the council for now that engagement
will be as an observer
which will allow us to speak in the
council participate in negotiations
and work with partners as the secretary
noted in his statement
we recognize the council's flaws but we
do believe that the best way to improve
it
is to work from within when it performs
as designed
the council can be a powerful tool to
promote fundamental freedoms
protect the rights of women girls lgbtqi
plus individuals
and other marginalized communities while
promoting accountability for human
rights violators
around the world next the united states
congratulates the people of ecuador for
ex
exercising their democratic right to
vote for their leaders we also
congratulate the many officials
public servants and volunteers whose
dedication made the vote possible
under the challenging conditions
presented by the global covid19 pandemic
while we await the final results of the
first round vote from the national
electoral council that will determine
the second place finisher
we urge people to remain calm and to
exercise patience
while ecuador's institutions finish
towing the votes and worked to resolve
conflicts in a peaceful
and transparent manner in accordance
with ecuador's constitution
and established norms and processes
finally
africa is a priority for the biden
administration in a video message
president biden extended greetings to
african leaders
and the african people as they gathered
for the 34th annual au summit
this past weekend we are committed to
engaging our african partners early and
often
in pursuing our shared interests and our
shared values
we will reinvigorate and restore our
relationships with the continent
building substantive reciprocal
partnerships with african governments
institution and people based on mutual
interests
and mutual respect so with that um matt
i'll turn over to you
thank you happy monday happy monday
um last night in the middle of the
football game although it wasn't a very
good game so
i read it intently when it came in uh
you put out a statement about uh
warning the houthis
about uh attacks against civilians
and um i i'm wondering
if the fact that you felt the need to
put out
that statement gives you any pause about
the decision that was made just two days
ago
or three well two days ago then three
days ago now friday
um to begin the process of de-listing
the houthis uh as a foreign terrorist
organization
um and if it it and if it doesn't give
you any pause about that
wha wha why not well matt we have been
very clear and we've been very clear
about uh two things
um in the first instance we've been very
clear and you heard the secretary from
this podium on his first
uh official day as secretary of state um
when asked about
his priorities for reviewing uh the
policies of the previous administration
he raised um he he he actually offered
um this designation of ansarella as
something he
uh prioritized uh to move upon
expeditiously
uh given the profound humanitarian
implications
of this designation i think he cited at
the time uh that 80 percent some 80
of yemen's civilian population lives
under houthi control in yemen
uh which is why of course we're
profoundly concerned um
for the humanitarian implications uh of
of that designation and so that's why um
uh we in fact did uh move very quickly
to
review that policy uh you may have heard
um from members of congress who have
been
vocal about this uh that we notified the
hill of the secretary's
intent to revoke the foreign terrorist
organization and
especially designated global terrorist
designations of anzarella
um we did that uh late last week we've
also been very clear about a second
element
um this intent to revoke that
designation has nothing to do
uh with our view of the houthis and
their reprehensible
conduct uh including as you mentioned
attacks against civilians and the
kidnapping
of american citizens among other moves
um we are committed as we again said uh
last night to helping saudi arabia
defend its territory against further
such attacks um
uh our planned action the secretary's
intent to
de-list um is due as i said before
to uh the humanitarian consequences um
of this last minute designation we can
do two things at once
uh we can ensure that we do not add to
the suffering of
yemeni civilians yemen now home to what
is believed to be
the world's worst humanitarian
catastrophe while um continuing to stand
um with saudi arabia um in the face of
these
attacks from the houthis aren't you i
mean
you say you can do two things at once
but by revoking this designation and the
sanctions that it entails
um aren't you helping the houthis and at
the same time
uh helping them attack in
what you said in your own statement last
night attacked civilians which
makes the civilian crisis even worse
no i i would dispute that i think
we will certainly keep up the pressure
on the leadership of the anzarella
movement of the houthis
we can do that um without the sort of
broad
designation the two designations that i
spoke to um
that do have uh tremendous uh pernicious
impacts on the humanitarian implications
of
the last thing on this on when you you
kept saying intent to
is there a chance that you might not go
through this no i've referred to the
intent
because uh in this matter and across the
board we intend to return to regular
order
um including regular regular order when
it comes to our um
interactions and consultations with
congress um the secretary wanted to
make sure that uh he had a prize
congress uh
of this intent as i mentioned before um
we did that last week um
uh and so it remains an intent as of now
yes humira
follow-up since we're on yemen uh the un
em and
envoy met with zarif today in iran to
discuss ending the conflict in yemen
does the united states believe
iran is still providing support to
houthis and
if so what kind of support after this
i'm gonna move on to another topic
uh well when it comes to our assessment
of the specific support that iran may be
providing to
the houthis um i would refer you uh some
of that may be um predicated in
uh intelligence channels i wouldn't want
to go too far into that what we have
said generally
uh is that iran has been a malign force
in the region
um we have spoken of its support for
proxies for
terrorist groups um its support for uh
the houthis as well i don't think we
want to go or at least i don't want to
go further today in
uh detailing that support um uh but if
we do have more to share we will
right and on myanmar so over the past
couple of days
tens of thousands of people have been
protesting
and uh against military coup and there's
a fear that the army
uh will move on them how close are you
in finalizing your action
in response to the military takeover and
the fact that these demonstrations and
the threat of the
army moving towards them does that add
the sense of urgency
well we've always operated with a
tremendous sense of urgency here that is
why
uh within hours of the military's coup
uh in burma we called it as such um i
think more broadly uh when it comes to
what we've seen in in recent days in
recent hours
um it is it is fair to say that we stand
uh with the dually elected
representatives of the people of burma
uh in their efforts to speak uh for the
people of the country
uh we join them in demanding the
immediate and full restoration of the
democratically elected government
we stand with the people of burma
support their right to
assemble peacefully including to protest
peacefully
in support of the democratically elected
government
and the rights of freedom of expression
including the freedom to seek to receive
uh to impart information both online uh
and
offline we're of course very concerned
about the military's recent
announcement restricting public
gatherings
as i said before we strongly support the
right of all individuals in burma and
around the world
to freedom of expression association
peaceful assembly
including for uh the purposes of
peaceful protest
uh when it comes to that review that you
mentioned we're of course taking a very
close look
um at the uh policy measures uh that we
could potentially enact
um should uh the military not not change
its course
um we are moving uh quickly uh in that
measure and we're doing so
i think consistent with the principle
that i outlined with matt in a very
different context
making sure that whatever we do um to
hold
the military to account uh for this coup
uh that we don't add to
um the humanitarian uh
the humanitarian concern of the people
of burma uh so we're we're doing that in
this case as well
can we come down to yemen hi
well let's stick with burma for just one
moment and then i'll come right back to
you okay thank you
thank you ned uh the the junta chief in
in
burma said that this time the military
rule will be different
promising free and fair elections at the
end of
the emergency period do you see that as
do you welcome this kind of statement or
is it clearly
a non-starter for you it's a non-starter
uh we've been very clear where we stand
uh we stand with uh the dually elected
representatives
of the people of burma we stand with the
people of burma
who are now peacefully uh taking to the
streets um
to exercise their universal rights we
stand with them
yes sure thanks
i just wanted to ask to what uh degree
this came up in the call between
secretary
lincoln and and uh yang jicho of china
was there any kind of effort to resolve
the um
situation in burma or was it the kind of
thing as
you know where there's just a
disagreement about uh
you know whether there's a need to uh
for the military to step back
well uh we did issue a readout uh
of that call um this has been a staple
of the secretary's calls
um with uh his counterparts uh since
february 1st since
the date of the coup we have been
encouraging china
both privately and in public to condemn
this action to join the international
community uh to join
um uh the united states and and those
other countries
uh a large swath of the world that has
spoken out uh in no uncertain terms
uh to condemn uh this anti uh democratic
action and to that end i would um point
you
to the statement that came out of the
u.n security council
last week it did have some strong
language of course
china did not stand in the way of that
but we continue to believe that
the chinese need to further condemn
uh what has taken place uh in burma in
recent days
have you for any u.s officials been in
touch with anzang suchi or any of the
detained nld leaders or the military
officials who are leading this junta and
then
are you considering in the face of the
curfews and the
uh crackdowns on protesters ordering
departure of non-emergency diplomats
from
the post there so uh on your final
question
um the uh we issued shortly after the
events of february first the coup on
february 1st
uh the u.s embassy uh the us mission in
burma issued
a message to american citizens there
they did full uh accounting full
accountability
uh for uh their personnel uh i'm not
aware of any plans uh
for a drawdown or an ordered departure
um at this time but of course those are
matters that we
continuously uh evaluate um
remind me of your previous question uh
have you been in touch with any of the
detainees so i'm gonna speak for
the department of state um i i will say
that shortly after the events of
february first um we made an effort
to reach out to aung sang sushi we did
that both uh
informally and we did that formally as
well those requests of course were
denied
i think i wanted to ask about a ross you
had a yemen question
oh i'm sorry yes it's okay um i had a
couple of more questions on yemen
uh number one yes reversing the sgt
and the fto designations does that
affect
the nixty act sanctions on
individual houthi leaders and then the
uk government announced earlier today
that it's going to continue selling
weapons systems to the saudis
and of course we all know the
controversy around the saudi involvement
in the yemeni civil war what is the us's
take
on uh downing street's decision is the
us going to talk
to the british about perhaps holding
back on war weapon sales in order to
promote the peace process
uh so on your uh second question
i think we'll let the british government
uh speak to their decisions when it
comes to
um their relationships with uh the saudi
government or or any other government
obviously
we have no closer partner the special
relationship um
uh in the bilateral relationship uh with
with london
um we uh are consistently sharing notes
sharing views
uh i think they they um and we have left
no doubt uh more broadly um where we
stand uh on this issue and you heard
uh late last week following um uh the
president's visit to
the department uh that we outlined uh a
new approach a new approach took steps
to
uh end uh the war in yemen a war that
has again
created a humanitarian catastrophe and a
strategic catastrophe
as well i'll run quickly um through
those steps that we took first we made
very clear that we are going to be
focused
intensely um on a diplomatic solution
working through the un-led process
uh and channels to restore the long
dormant
peace talks uh we'll work closely with
the u.n
envoy martin griffiths and you heard the
president himself
name tim linderking as our special envoy
to the conflict second um as we said
last week as well
we're ending all american support for
offensive operations
in yemen including those relevant arms
sales
as we said at the time this does not
apply to our operations
against aqap but it does include both
material and restricting our
intelligence sharing
relationships with saudi arabia uh in
the saudi-led coalition
uh in accordance with um the the
president's guidance and then third we
also made clear as i was um
mentioning to matt um that we do
understand in the midst of all this
saudi arabia faces a
genuine security threats from yemen
which we again saw um
over uh the weekend uh and so as part of
the interagency
process and the interagency process that
will
be on this review future potential
weapons transfers we will look for ways
to improve support um
for saudi arabia's ability uh to defend
itself uh and its territory against
threats
thank you rich thanks um as you uh
mentioned earlier the administration has
no interest in playing fto whiplash
here and returning um the who
designation but
is there something that the
administration is considering doing
short of an fto designation any type of
sanctions that the administration
would um to sort of go with the or else
of your statement from yesterday
well i think rich we've been very clear
um that
the houthis uh are malign actors um
their com
their conduct as i said before is
reprehensible um
uh the way in which they have afflict
the
the um manner in which they have
inflicted suffering
um on the people of yemen the people
they
uh purport to govern um uh their
neighbors um the threat they pose to
our interests um in yemen uh several
years back um
that is why we we can and will continue
to keep up the pressure
um on the ansara on the houthi
leadership
um just as we take uh these steps that
uh
have received bipartisan uh strong
bipartisan support
um to ensure that we are not uh
worsening the humanitarian suffering of
the people of yemen we can do both
things
at the same time andrea
related but uh first thank you for your
comments about secretary schultz it
means a lot to a lot of people here
um on iran the ayatollah statement
followed up of course by fareed's
interview with foreign minister zarif
seem to shut down any possibility of
any progress until the u.s lifts
sanctions
help us understand what wiggle room
there is in that
i know you're not going to negotiate
here but well
you uh you saw my line um i am i'm not
going to negotiate
uh you see that as you know a dead end
uh so we don't see this broader uh uh
this broader opportunity as a dead end
at all um
the proposal um and you have heard it uh
for months now
um from the uh then candidate biden and
now president biden has been very clear
if iran is willing to resume full
compliance with the jcpoa
we will re-enter that deal as well
we will seek to lengthen and strengthen
its provisions including vis-a-vis the
nuclear provisions using
it as a platform uh to um
then negotiate follow-on agreements
um that would uh address iran's other
malign activities some of which we've
already uh discussed
uh in this briefing i think uh rather
than uh
negotiate here from the podium what i
will do is point to
what we have been doing uh really since
uh the early days of this administration
i suppose we still are in the early days
of this administration
i when it comes to the coordination with
our allies
with our partners with members of
congress uh we spoke i believe it was on
friday uh about
secretary blinken's uh participation in
a meeting with
uh the e3 uh iran of course did feature
into that um
we offered a readout of that interaction
the secretary has of course been in
touch with
bilaterally with our european uh allies
uh with other um uh with other
counterparts
who were either part of the original p5
plus one
um or uh of course who do have um uh
an interest uh in this going forward so
those consultations that coordination uh
is ongoing um uh as with uh congress as
well
uh i think rather than uh respond uh
to comments that may be emanating from
tehran um we're going to
do our own consultations um ensure that
we are synchronized that we're
harmonized
with our closest partners and go from a
position of strength from there yes
are there other incentives that we can
offer iran such as
not opposing imf loans and
other financial incentives that they
could get which would not technically be
a lifting of sanctions
and is there any uh effort to reach out
bilateral
uh so on your second question uh again
our focus has been
um on engaging uh both in multilateral
and bilateral flora
with our partners uh and allies um uh
when it comes to
um any engagement with the iranians
we're we're not there yet um
we want to again make sure that we have
our ducks in a row
with our closest friends our closest uh
partners and allies
as well as with uh the institution of
the united states congress
um when it comes to humanitarian
gestures the
the elements you mentioned uh i think
that would probably fall in the category
of negotiating from the podium so i
wouldn't want to
uh i wouldn't want to go there um uh but
again
we are going to uh uh make sure
that uh we are in uh the same on the
same page
as our partners our allies um that we
have um
uh that we have uh undertaken those
consultations with congress
um before uh uh we were we would
um uh allude to any of those measures
um did you see the date of
february 21st when uh hirano said
it will stop following the additional
protocol
within the inspections requirements do
you see that as
a deadline for your full compliance for
full compliance or some
kind of redline that they shouldn't
trust no
uh on february 21st if iran has not
uh resumed full compliance um with the
deal iran will
still be out of compliance with the deal
by by definition um
uh what we have put on the table is that
uh we are looking for
iran to resume its full compliance um
of course as you just alluded to with
your question iran is
quite a ways out of compliance uh in a
number of specific areas
so we aren't looking to any particular
date
we are looking for iran to
indicate its willingness um to
go along with the proposition that um as
a candidate um
uh vice president biden put on the table
and the proposition that remains on the
table today
on iran uh we'll let's move around a
little bit yes
uh also on iran how does this
administration intend to deal with the
hostage
situation um obviously the the iranians
are still holding
including one american uh namazu i mean
sorry uh siamak namazi who was picked up
during
the obama administration that's right um
uh
look the secretary uh was asked about
this i believe
uh in one of his um uh or his first
broadcast interview
um and uh he made very clear
that um we have no higher priority uh
than the safe return of americans who
are being held unjustly uh around the
world
uh of course that uh includes uh in
iran we are
you know that we have a special envoy in
this building
there is a hostage recovery fusion cell
that is working elements of these cases
as well
we can do these things uh in in parallel
but do you have any sort of have you
launched any negotiations on this
specifically
with um iran are you opening up channels
to talk about that and are you working
with partners because the iranians are
holding many other foreign nationals so
as you know the swiss are protecting
power
um within within iran uh we um
coordinate very closely with them uh
they represent um those interests for us
uh when it comes to american citizens
who are being held
in iran i wouldn't want to detail what
may be
going on behind closed doors um but
suffice to say we have no higher
priority
than the release of american citizens
who are detained unjustly around the
world including uh
in iran anything else on iran before we
move on um
we'll go here and then yes okay you just
said um
you don't see this broader opportunity
as a dead end is it because like
the comments from the supreme leader
like irreversible and final do you see
them as just
posturing and then could the
administration be considering something
less for less like you guys will
give some economic relief but not
nothing
too big in return for like iran halting
some of the violations
i i wouldn't want to speculate as to
what may undergird
uh comments from the supreme leader
comments from the iranian president
uh comments from others in the iranian
context nor would i again want to
negotiate from the podium so
um we'll probably leave that there
rosalind i'll figure backing on your
comments that
iran is already out of compliance there
are reports that iaea
inspectors may have found evidence of
radioactive material at two
sites that the iranians had blocked them
from searching last year
but after negotiation they apparently
made it to these sites
found evidence of possible nuclear
weapons related activity
is there any comment from this podium
given that there hasn't been formal
notification
to member states of the iaea well on
that i would need to refer you to
the iaea um i do think it is uh
a worthwhile reminder um of the
provisions of the 2015
iran deal that we are attempting um that
we would like to see
iran uh resume full compliance with um
iran as i mentioned before has distanced
itself um from that agreement in any
number of ways the 25th deal 2015 deal
limits uh enriched uranium stockpile
uh it puts a cap on enrichment uh
levels uh 3.67 percent uh it
uh limits the uh the
centrifuges um that iran is uh allowed
to have it limits its
r d um it limits its heavy water
stockpile
um uh and i think most importantly in an
element that is often overlooked
um iran under the uh nuclear
deal um uh and under the non-proliferat
non-proliferation treaty uh there is a
permanent prohibition on iran ever
obtaining a nuclear weapon uh and so
that's why we think it is so important
that as a starting point that iran
resume uh that full compliance
uh with the nuclear deal that's why it's
been the predicate uh of our
diplomatic path that we've put forward
iran resumes that full compliance
the united states will do the same we'll
then undertake uh diplomacy to lengthen
strengthen
uh the the uh provisions and to use it
again uh as
uh not the ceiling but the floor for
follow-on agreements to take on
uh other elements of iran's malign
activity michelle
any comment on the formation of the
government there
i will we can get back to you on that um
we'll take that question
okay and the second on lebanon uh
political and religious leaders
and lebanon are calling for an
international conference under the un
uh auspices to protect the constitution
and put an end to the multiplicity of
arms uh does the u.s support such goals
and to what extent the u.s support uh
supports the french initiative in
lebanon
well um you saw uh last week it was that
uh secretary blinken uh together with
his uh french counterpart
um uh did put out a very strong um uh
statement uh of support um
for uh the people of of lebanon it was
pegged to
the six-month anniversary of the uh
deadly and horrific
blast in in beirut so i would uh refer
you there if we have any additional
comment we'll be able to provide that
international conference do you support
if we have any additional comment we'll
be able to get back to you
do you accept i mean you just said in
response to the last iran question that
iran has distanced itself from the deal
in
in many ways okay but you do accept that
the united states actually
walked away from the deal pulled out
withdrew maybe not
this administration but you do accept
that the united states
pulled out of the deal right i think
that's the reality i wouldn't i wouldn't
dispute that
okay uh so you're you're so you're you
know when you when you're
so you you're starting from you know
from a
position behind the starting line here
you accept that or no uh i think what i
would accept
is that uh we have outlined consistently
and clearly a
path forward um for uh uh
diplomacy um for iran um uh a path
forward for diplomacy that you know we
are intent to
engage um closely with our allies and
partners members of congress on
um you know i'm not going to um stand
here and
um i don't want to uh speak um for the
previous administration i'm speaking for
this administration and speaking for our
path forward
okay uh secondly on the uh the unhcr
hrc uh decision this morning
uh taking note of that also taking note
of the fact that you guys have said that
yes it's got problems and we want to
reform it we want to do it from within
one of those problems
the previous administration cited and
pulling out of it
withdrawing from it uh was an
anti-israel
bias and i i want to
ask about that but also your the
secretary's comments last week about the
international criminal court
and um its uh decision which you
we talked about um on the phone on
friday
um but if you are uh sitting in israel
right now why should you not think that
these two
positions one palestine does not have a
is not a state party is not a state and
it can
and it should not be allowed to bring a
case
before the icc and then
the decision to rejoin or to return to
the
um right human rights council as an
observer
um after what you accept as an
anti-israel bias i i believe
um you know how how do you square this
you know if you're
sitting in israel how how should you
take these two things well um i think
this
uh first of all of course we put out i
think of what was a very strong
statement um
in the aftermath of the icc ruling um
that statement's made clear um as we
made clear when the palestinians
purported to join
uh the rome statute in 2015 um that we
don't believe
um the palestinians qualify as a
sovereign state uh and therefore are not
qualified to obtain membership as a
state
or to participate um as a state in
international organizations
entities or conferences uh including uh
the icc will continue to uphold
president biden's strong commitment to
israel and its security
including opposing actions that seek to
target israel unfairly that takes me
uh to the decision we announced earlier
today
and i think our orient orienting
principle here is that the united states
can be a constructive force that we can
help
shape um the course of world events we
can help shape international
institutions when we're present
when we're at the table um we believe
that the united states
plays a constructive role on the council
when we play a constructive role on our
on the council in concert with our
allies and partners
positive change is possible it is within
reach
you outlined one of those reforms that
is necessary the council's
disproportionate focus
on israel um uh and second um i think
ensuring countries
um that ensuring countries with strong
human rights records uh
serve on uh the council um we
firmly believe um that states with the
worst human rights record don't belong
on the human rights council um on both
of these elements
um uh it is our view that the best way
for us to reform them to improve
uh the council as an institution is to
engage uh to engage with it to engage
with its members
uh in a principled fashion and that's
what we intend to do in the first
instance as an observer i know we're
running out of time so
um uh yes please thank you a couple of
quick questions on latin america
shifting a bit
what kind of reaction have you been
getting so far from the northern
triangle
central american countries after pulling
out of the
asylum cooperation agreements on
saturday i think it was
and secondly on venezuela all of the
readouts i'm
seeing unless i missed something of of
the secretary's calls with various world
leaders
i saw venezuela only mentioned once is
that why is that is does that reflect
a lack of fresh ideas and strategy or
why is that
why aren't we not seeing that come up
more no
look uh readouts are obviously a
snapshot um these
these oftentimes are lengthy
conversations um and
uh readouts typically are not lengthy
documents um i
i so it is it is very fair to say that
venezuela has been a topic
um with uh you know many of the
secretary's uh
closest many of our um closest uh
friends um
allies and partners across the region
but um also in in europe and elsewhere
um it uh uh and it will continue to be
the case i think a defining hallmark
um of our strategy uh to uh
help the people of venezuela achieve
their
uh legitimate aspirations for democracy
will be a coordinated
uh approach and we talked about um i i
recall very distinctly with matt
the uh approach we will take with our
partners um
bilaterally and then in multilateral for
as well to ensure that we are achieving
that outcome for the people of venezuela
when it comes to the termination of the
asylum cooperative agreements this was
something that president biden
committed to when he was a candidate on
the campaign trail it is a
broader element of the president's
commitment to
a regional migration plan
and a regional migration strategy
that takes into account the root causes
of migration
that sees um countries in the regions
in the region including uh those in the
northern triangle uh as
as true partners um as the secretary's
statement uh over the weekend regarding
the
um uh the end of the aca is made clear
that we've notified
those countries we've been in touch at
different levels
this was not something that came as a
surprise to them
and we look forward to continuing uh to
work with
our partners in the northern triangle on
our strategy to regional migration
that addresses many of those drivers
many of those drivers that have
over the course of years
left those in the region with few
perceived options rather than to migrate
north our
strategy is predicated on the idea that
we can give opportunity um
to those in the region and
remove some of the inducements that they
might otherwise have to undertake the
very dangerous
journey um to the united states a
journey that is currently made all the
more dangerous um
by uh covet uh and of course those who
would seek to take advantage
of those um uh fleeing their their home
countries so
i know we've gone on for uh quite some
time kim i see you earnestly raising
your hand in the back
please thank you um if burma
is the first test of the vibe
administration's
goal to pull together allies and produce
change
what are your levers to produce that
change in behavior because the peterson
institute looked at
more than two decades of sanctions
against
myanmar burma and found it didn't
produce
any change at the top the trump
administration sanctioned
uh the top coup leaders last fall that
didn't produce any change
how are you going to get them to change
how they're treating
the people on the ground well the united
states over the course of years
um has been um the
uh most uh ardent supporter of the
people of burma
um we've talked about some of that
financial aid
in recent days i think you heard me say
the other day that the united states
provides nearly 135 million dollars in
bilateral assistance to burma this was
for
fy uh uh 2020. um but beyond that
um in fy 2020 we provided more than 469
million
uh in humanitarian assistance um to uh
uh to the people of burma bringing the
u.s total contribution since
august of 2017 to nearly 1.2 billion
dollars
um and that figure is for all of those
affected by the
by the violence within burma um as well
as those who have been
uh forced to flee um and to um
flee to bangladesh and and throughout
the region so uh
the united states um has been um uh the
world's foremost
um supporter um uh we do have um
quite a bit of leverage but as with
every challenge
we have all the more leverage um when we
work closely with our
allies and partners um including in this
case with our
uh like-minded allies and partners we've
spoken to
uh one source of leverage that we are um
studying very closely right now
after the designation of the of the
events of february 1st as a coup
um we're very cl we're looking very
closely um
at additional um sanctions that we might
be able to enact
um on uh the on those responsible for
this coup
uh national security advisor sullivan uh
last week also spoke of the potential
for
um additional executive actions uh so
the united states remains the most
powerful country in the world
um there is no doubt about that but when
we bring our allies and partners along
with us
they act as force multipliers we have
the ability to galvanize collective
action
um to confront uh challenges the world
over in a way that no other country does
um that's what we've been doing on burma
um since even
before the coup to address the
humanitarian
challenges of the burmese people
including the rohingya
and since february 1st working very
concertedly with our like-minded allies
and partners to ensure that we're
working in lockstep and so that when we
do
announce um uh the additional measures
um that they will provide uh
all the more inducement to return um
burma to its democratic civilian
leadership thank you everyone i think
we'll
call that a day we'll do this again
tomorrow so appreciate this